hemos tratado a la luz como una onda y
la hemos dibujado como una ondulación
con una ruta continua de campos
oscilatorios magnéticos y eléctricos que
viajan en cierta dirección y por qué no
deberíamos tratarla como onda si cuando
la hacemos pasar por una ranura esta
radiación electromagnética se va a
dispersar tendrá difracción que es cómo
se comportan las ondas o si dejamos que
se superponga consigo misma
tenemos una onda en cierta región y se
le alinea perfectamente con otra onda
electromagnética tendremos interferencia
constructiva y si la onda está desfasada
entonces tendremos interferencia
destructiva que es lo que las ondas
hacen así que por qué no deberíamos
llamar onda a la radiación
electromagnética esto es lo que todos
pensaban pero a finales del siglo 19 y
principios del siglo 20 los científicos
descubrieron algo sorprendente
descubrieron que la luz y toda la
radiación electromagnética mostraban
comportamiento de partículas y no me
refiero a que esté localizada en una
región del espacio ya que las ondas
bien pueden encontrarse en un lugar en
el espacio si enviamos aquí una onda que
sea un pulso el pulso de esta onda está
localizado pues está viajando por aquí y
él luce como una partícula pero no es a
esto a lo que nos referimos nosotros
hablamos de algo más dramático nos
referimos a que los físicos descubrieron
que la luz las partículas de luz solo
pueden depositar cierta cantidad de
energía en particular sólo cantidades
discretas de energía hay cierto pedazo
de energía que es lo que la luz puede
entregar no más y no menos que eso y es
por eso que les llamamos mecánica
cuántica lo de cuántico significa un
salto discreto no menos que esto así que
como le llamamos a estas partículas de
luz les llamamos fotones y como los
dibujamos no es tan sencillo ahora
sabemos que la luz se comporta como onda
y como partícula así que podemos
dibujarlos como pequeñas líneas
onduladas aquí tenemos un fotón aquí
tenemos otro fotón y este es el problema
principal
la dualidad onda partícula el hecho de
que la luz y todo lo demás puede tener
propiedades de onda y de partícula no
conocemos nada parecido a esto y no
podemos visualizarlo mentalmente porque
nada en nuestra experiencia cotidiana se
comporta así tanto como onda y como
particular al mismo tiempo por lo que
nos es casi imposible dibujar una
representación visual de esto pero
siempre es bueno dibujar algo y por eso
dibujamos así a los fotones lo que
quiero decir es que imaginen que tenemos
un detector aquí que puede medir la
energía de la luz que recibe de una
fuente de luz si este detector es lo
suficientemente sensible entonces
detectará nada de energía o un salto o
nada de energía y hoy de nuevo un salto
no podrá detectar nada intermedio
imaginad que el salto es de tres
unidades de energía no especificamos que
unidades sólo decimos que son tres
unidades de energía si ésta fuera la
cantidad de energía
de un fotón y esos fotones tuvieran tres
unidades de energía podríamos detectar
nada de energía y únicamente tres
unidades de energía completas no podemos
absorber la mitad de esta energía ni
puedo absorber una unidad de energía o
dos unidades de energía o se absorbe
todo o no se absorbe nada y es por eso
que es mecánica cuántica por el
comportamiento discreto de la luz que
deposita toda su energía como una
partícula o nada en absoluto cuánta
energía tenemos una fórmula para esto la
cantidad de energía en un fotón se
determina por la fórmula la constante de
planck h h es la letra que usamos para
la constante de planck la multiplicamos
por efe y es una fórmula muy sencilla
esta f es la frecuencia y cuánto valen
la constante de planck plank fue
básicamente el padre de la mecánica
cuántica y fue el primero en calcular el
valor de esta constante y propuso que la
luz sólo puede depositar su energía en
edades discretas la constante de planck
es extremadamente pequeña 6.626 por 10 a
la menos 34 jules por segundo 10 a la
menos 34 hay pocas cantidades en la
física que sean tan pequeñas como esta
se multiplica por la frecuencia que es
la frecuencia regular el número de
oscilaciones por segundo medida en hertz
ahora vamos a tratar de averiguar por
qué los físicos no habían encontrado
esto antes y la razón es que la
constante de planck es tan pequeña que
la energía de estos fotones es
extremadamente pequeña la granularidad
de esta cantidad de energía que está
siendo depositada es tan pequeña que
luce casi plana y no podemos distinguir
la existencia de algo tan pequeño o al
menos es muy difícil hacerlo aquí yo me
inventé esto de tres unidades pero la
cantidad real
para digamos la luz violeta la energía
de un fotón de luz violeta es la
frecuencia de la luz violeta 7.5 por 10
a la 14 hertz así que tomamos este
número y lo multiplicamos por la
constante de planck 6.626 por 10 a la
menos 34 soles por segundo y tenemos que
la energía de un fotón violeta es de 5
por 10 a la menos 19 25 por 10 a la
menos 19 jules es extremadamente pequeño
algo muy difícil de notar el que la
energía discreta sea tan pequeña es como
el agua imaginen el agua en el lavabo
agua que escurre afuera del lavabo luce
continua aunque sabemos que en realidad
son moléculas individuales y podemos
tener moléculas de agua o ausencia de
moléculas de agua o cantidades discretas
de moléculas de agua pero son tantas y
tan pequeñas que no podemos
distinguirlas individualmente y nos
parece el agua completamente continua
lo mismo sucede con esta luz la energía
de cada uno de estos fotones violetas es
muy pequeña de hecho si quieren saber
qué tan pequeña es imaginen una pelota
de béisbol y a un jugador profesional de
béisbol imaginen que al jugador le
lanzan una bola rápida y la va a batear
con unos 100 jules de energía cuantos
fotones necesitaremos para igualar la
energía con la que se batió la pelota de
béisbol necesitaremos 2 trillones de
estos fotones para igualar la energía
usada en este batazo y es por eso que no
vemos esto a escala macroscópica así que
básicamente la luz es continua a nivel
macroscópico puede depositar lo que
quiera de energía porque la escala es
tan pequeña pero si la vemos de cerca
nos daremos cuenta de que la luz solo
puede depositar energía en cantidades
discretas aunque con esto no quiero
decir que la luz solo deposite
cantidades pequeñas de energía la luz
también puede depositar cantidades
grandes
de energía pero la entrega también en
cantidades discretas vamos a quitar todo
esto y pensemos lo de esta manera vamos
a tener un receptor que registra la
cantidad de energía que absorbe y la
gráfica como la cantidad de energía por
el tiempo aquí tenemos los ejes de
energía por tiempo y ahora el detector a
nivel macroscópico vemos que absorbe una
gran cantidad de energía y la gráfica a
nivel macroscópico puede verse así en
donde tenemos cada vez más energía pero
microscópicamente si viéramos esto
notaremos que aquí se absorbió la
energía de un fotón aquí se absorbió
otro aquí otros más y seguimos
absorbiendo muchos de estos fotones que
se acumulan así que estamos absorbiendo
mucha energía lo cual está muy bien pero
si vemos esto muy de cerca notaremos
este patrón de escalera que surge de
absorber una cantidad particular de
fotones individuales quizás se
absorbieron tres simultáneamente y en
otro momento se absorbieron 4 pero
podemos absorber algo intermedio como
una fracción de fotón para que esto se
vuelva completamente continuo tiene que
ser una absorción de energía de todo o
nada con cada fotón aunque luzca suave y
parejo a escala macroscópica a escala
microscópica resalta el hecho de que la
energía de la luz llega en porciones
discretas descritas por esta ecuación
que nos da la energía de fotones
individuales